for those who think that we're going to
be living our lives completely online
uh it's not going to happen you know
there's nothing that's going to replace
good old-fashioned human interaction
um and for the one person who gets back
on a plane to go visit a client
and makes that client feel special then
we're all going to be on planes
having business trips again um and so
we're not going to be living in an
online world for the rest of our lives
but
there is a comfort with the online
medium now that it'll be more blended in
i think online has been going to become
uh more flexible for example
companies might give people the
opportunity to work from home or come to
the office whenever they want or
tuesdays and thursdays we all come to
the office that's when we have all
office meetings for example
um the point is it's going to become a
little bit different it is going to
become a little more flexible i think
one of the things that i think is is
very interesting is the rise of
new tech especially in the financial
world so for example i'll give you a
real life experience
i tried uh robin hood because i wanted
to see what all the hubbub was about no
i did not invest in gamestop
um and um uh compare that to my fidelity
account
you know so for me to make a trade on on
on uh
on robinhood is so easy it's just so
user friendly you just
plug in a couple numbers it's completely
intuitive and off you go you're off to
the races if i log on to my fidelity
account it's excruciating
it's absolutely completely unintuitive
and the reason is
is because robinhood is a tech company
that just happens to be in finance
where fidelity is a finance company
that's struggling to do the tech thing
so one the tech company knows that user
experience is absolutely essential to
good tech
the finance company it's all about the
finance not about the technology
so recognizing how our customers are
living their lives
whether meaning through a phone or
online means by presenting ourselves
as a tech company that happens to be in
finance or in you know
selling insurance or financial planning
whatever it is versus
how am i just going to put everything
that i've always been doing but do it
online
you're going to miss the boat and this
is why these new tech companies
whether it's amazon or netflix or all of
these companies
they they put the incumbents out of
business robin hood is giving fidelity a
run for its money
not because it offers a more robust
product it doesn't but because
it's just easier to use it's more
intuitive um so i think how you view
yourself what kind of company are you
are you
are you mired in your product are you
mired in in the way you should be
servicing your clients i think that's a
big way to reinvent ourselves